our next guest is Dwayne Perkins the
actor writer and producer is known for
his work on the upshaws and the Saved by
the Bell reboot the New York Times named
him one of the queer young comets
redefining American humor now Perkins is
co-writer producer and star of the new
comedy horror film The blackening now
here's what it does it follows a group
of black friends who reunite for a
weekend getaway and find themselves
trapped by a crazy killer and through
the humor it takes on racial tropes in
Hollywood here's a clip
[Music]
this is good or bad wait how do we know
we can trust him
I'm one of the good ones oh that does
not help they all say that that actually
makes you seem more suspicious you can
trust me seriously if I got an invite to
the cookout I'd be honored but it
wouldn't go and why not because I know
my presence in that all black space will
be a disturbance so don't do it being an
all-black space
pretty good answer absolutely where's me
it's like we're gonna lower our hands
lower away okay great look I've never
been so happy to see a white savior
somebody's trying to kill us please help
us please
Dwayne Perkins joins us right now all
glammed out how you doing I'm doing very
well thank you guys for having me okay
so before we start I have to say as you
can see we love our our hair uh and we
are doing our thing this Trio this
morning but you won the award for best
hair oh thank you thank you
okay so the idea behind the blackening
is that if black people always die in
the beginning of horror films what
happens if everybody is black exactly uh
so so how does this movie answer that
question uh it answers it by uh letting
people know that there is no answer on
how to quantify Blackness uh and if you
watch the movie you'll see exactly how
we did it I don't want to give away too
many spoilers of course uh but there are
a lot of ways in which we um
dissect tropes and really
um speak to the history that black
people have had in horror and a very fun
entertaining way now the blackening is
also based on the Comedy Central sketch
um this was a handful of years ago
um so how does it feel to see this come
to life uh kind of crazy I just really
didn't anticipate where this could go
yeah I wrote a sketch because I needed
to write a sketch right and kind of
every step of the way I thought was like
a new win when we because the sketch
started on stage right and when we
filmed it for Comedy Central I said wow
so many more people can see it and then
when it went viral I'll say oh I've
never had something go viral what a win
and then when Tracy Oliver watched it
and called me and she just said hey I
think this could be a movie and I said
well you know more than me uh
sure and that was an even bigger one and
then Tiff Tribeca is just continuously
has been so surprising as to how much
good has come out of this project so in
the movie the characters have to
basically compete and they're trying to
identify who is the blackest which
everyone is now trying to not be so
they're not the one
which is absolutely hilarious as a
comedian how do you navigate that
political correctness because you're
putting some wild things out there some
stereotypes but also having fun with it
yes uh I feel like I've been asked this
question often just because comedy and
there's this whole idea of like what can
you cannot say and I just think it's
fairly simple to not be offensive I
think if you really think about what you
want to say in the intent behind it that
there's nothing that I feel like I
cannot justify
um and I think it's very easy to kind of
give to speak on these tropes because
it's about expanding people's perception
of like how they're perceiving these
characters right particularly black
characters queer characters and forcing
them to question themselves and the
boxes that they've created and using the
film to let people know that oh we're so
much more than what we are being allowed
to be and when you give space to these
marginalized voices to these characters
that we only see as tropes they no
longer become tropes they become fully
realized people
so it's not only uh black characters
right it's the best gay friend character
or best yeah best friend take it away
from there
I said well you don't worry about
stepping on lines I on the other hand
this movie would hit different if I
wrote it and I was just like I'm gonna
let him find it uh yeah so like my
character is a gay best friend and that
is a Trope that is often used in film as
a tool to further The Narrative of
someone in the lead which is normally
not the queer person so being able to
put that person in the Forefront and
prioritize that person it instantly
takes away from it being a Trope and you
start to see oh tropes are just us
putting people in a box and only
allowing them to be one thing but when
you let that best that gay best friend
actually like
give time and space to the friendship
you realize oh this is a real
relationship that has legs that can be
applied that the gay best friend could
also be a villain they could be a hero
there's just so much more that they can
be and as a queer actor I felt like I
have often been put in boxes so having
the opportunity to really push that
narrative forward to something I'm so
proud of and uh very grateful that I got
to play that part with the writer strike
going on you know I'm curious to get
your opinion about the landscape of the
industry being a writer yourself
um you know I know you understand the
concept of not just finding your place
but occupying space yeah with your
elbows out how do you feel about what's
going on with the writer strike and then
real quick what would you what type of
advice would you give to someone who is
trying to break into this industry as a
writer I think what you said is very
true about taking up space and I think
you have to really have a strong sense
of self to be able to stand in these
spaces that are very challenging and I
think as a queer black man growing up in
Chicago I had those challenges very
early so I just really was able to build
a strong self-love a strong sense and
stuff so when I enter these spaces I
don't have fear yeah I know that I can
bring something that is not here and
that's why I'm here and that is my
purpose uh And in regards to the wga
strike that is very much in line of art
like you have to give people the support
to create good art uh and if they don't
have that then the art will suffer yeah
and so I'm very much in line give the
writers what they need so that art can
continue to be Artful well said Dwayne
Perkins we appreciate you thank you for
stopping by being here the blackening
opens in theaters this Friday